alright we are live hello everyone that
we're doing a hangout with Kim castle
and Kim is the founder of brand you Kim
welcome aboard how you doing I'm great
thank you so much for having me you know
what we've been family for so long it's
so great to finally meet you yeah so for
everybody watching Kim has been an offer
on my website for I don't know how long
has been it's been years contributing
content people loved her stuff so I
thought hey we should have her on share
some advice for for entrepreneurs Kim
but to start off Juanita's let everybody
know what it is that you do uh well it's
interesting because I'm in a great
transition as so many people aren't
these days but it really is a
continuation of everything that I've
been doing really for about 25 years
I've been a brand development working
with big brands helping people big
brands from IBM General Motors Disney
mm's Wolfgang Puck but about 10 years
ago I realized that the way big
businesses were operating wasn't it just
wasn't sustainable and that I really
wanted to work with entrepreneurs and
give them the same power that the big
brands had in terms of the the brand in
terms of knowing what it is they're
really offering the customer in the
world and really owning it and owning
the communication so we created brand
you to basically leverage everything
that I was doing for the big brands to
entrepreneurs and help them be the new
brands of tomorrow and in my transition
now I'm actually taking what I do with
brand and what I did for many years
alongside was media digital media and
really it's the the beautiful blend of
digital media brand commerce marketing
and really connecting with people and
its really where I stand today that's
cool that's great so what's what does a
typical client look like for you look at
the person you help it really depends on
what they're needing if they're wanting
to really they have an idea and they
want to go okay how do I really expand
this as a sustainable feasible mass
brand and they need / help produc
producing it conceiving it coming up
with the whole business model how do you
actually develop the the the initial
flow or the drip to bring them in and
then if they want to then roll it out
through media whether its publication
whether it's video then we can help them
create shows take the brand into a wider
wider communication beyond just
information marketing it's really
understanding how to put people into
experience got it so what are some of
the biggest problems you see with
entrepreneurs we're coming to you how
can you help them a couple of different
things one is there's so much
information there's so much stuff
spinning people around and it used to be
up until about five years ago it used to
just be a lot of the information
overload now it's it's it's overload on
so many different levels it's so many
different social media platforms so many
different tools so many different
approaches and there and every approach
isn't the right approach for the
individual nor the brand nor the brand
to market reach and so most people are
just running after all these different
possibilities as opposed to picking the
right ones that work for them their
brand and market reach hmm how do you
get over so I mean a lot of
entrepreneurs uh they're not they're not
thinking brand you know they feel brain
is to the big guys I sales I have you
come back you know what you have to
realize that you are a brand whether you
do it or not you are people have a
perception about you and the same people
that shop at Nike shop at Bob's shoe
present bonanza and yeah if yours Bob
shoe Bonanza you have to realize that
your competition is Nike even though you
don't think you're it is your cut your
you're the customers do because the
bigger brands create the percents of
value or perceived value and if you're
not playing in the same communication
arena then you've already shot yourself
in the foot I think a important thing to
think about in brand is it's not just
the slick exterior it's not
for the big brands it's it's everything
that you are everything that you stand
for and that's first and foremost where
we start is we pull down the blinds you
know separating you that the brand
creator to the market and go okay let's
get into the core of what you're really
about because if you don't know that you
can't stand in that soul centered place
of your brand there's no way you're
going to last in the marketplace you're
going to get trampled do you usually
recommend for entrepreneurs to build a
personal brand around themselves no I do
not okay so uh why is that and what's
your recommendation okay there's
fiercest there's how very very
passionate about that subject so thank
you so much for asking that um but the
reason I say no so adamantly is I think
what happens is people start to have
like kind of like Chinatown syndrome is
it my brand is at me it's my Brandon you
can't they start to mother sister they
get confused as what is it what are they
communicating yes you have to know
thyself you know Buddha says know
thyself but you have to realize that
you're creating a business first and
foremost if you're creating a brand it's
a business you may decide to lend it
your personality your face your whatever
like Oprah or Martha Stewart or Rachael
Ray or anybody like that but first and
foremost it's a business and you have to
realize i think i think by saying a
personal brand all that came out of like
Tom Peters back in the early 90s when he
was talking about personal brand and it
was really about an individual knowing
their worth in a corporate setting you
know develop your personal brand you are
valuable you know you you leave awake so
to speak in excuse me now we
fast-forward to social media and you see
all these people excuse me I have that
same water bottle oh you do one litre
three of these a day's guys three of
these a day healthy um um look fast
forward to today to social media and you
see all these people stepping up and
personal brand personal brand and
they're saying do personal brand I think
it's an it's it's
it's confusing and misleading and I
think your brand has to stand for
something not just Who am I that's kind
of a your business and so create a
business and then if you want to get
lend at your face lend it your
personality then you know what you're
doing because if you do it opposite and
your it's your personal brand right
you're just doing a personal brand and
you're trying to get people to buy into
you as an individual what if you grow
what if you change your stock so if we
blow this out to all the communications
and we're looking at social media and
our Facebook and Twitter do you
recommend businesses having their own
accounts and end of the CEO wants to
have their account that's a separate
thing or do you recommend merging them
together I think they could have I mean
in this day and age people are wanting
to do business with people so you still
have that personal level I mean you're
still a human being so I don't want I
don't let me sorry somebody's calling me
I think in terms of counts you mean in
like a Twitter account or tumblr account
and things like that well one that
platforms won't let you just be a
non-person you know they won't let you
do that they want a person at the helm
of each account but second people
connect to people so you still have a
role as a CEO of you're still a human
being and so your role is the human
being you still have to play that but
it's not like you're creating a separate
brand from the company your individual
representing what this company is about
and you do you recommend people go
through this process right at the
beginning of studying their business
when they're not necessarily sure what
products or services salad or where do
you come along process absolutely i
think from the very beginning if you
start out thinking that you're building
a brand from the very beginning you'll
take it a lot more seriously you won't
just throw things at this refrigerator
hoping the spaghetti will stick and you
will proceed with a strength and a
knowing of what it is you're developing
even if you just have an idea like oh I
have this problem that I want to solve
let's say vacuum cleaners keep breaking
and I want to
create the best vacuum cleaner you know
I'm tired of buying a vacuum cleaner
that you start with the problem then you
go to the brand then you go to the
products if you want a sustainable if
you want a sustainable long-lasting
company now if you're just wanting like
flip houses if you just want to flip a
business you may not want to go to that
effort you may want to just say hey let
me see let me convince the market of
this this product right and see if it
works and there are some people that do
that you find the people come to you
often too late in the process like
they've already gone down the road and
you have to reengineer everything for
them very often yeah that's sad it makes
me really really sorry for people that
have wasted so much time so much money
and really even more precious is their
own belief their own belief in what
they're doing because somebody sold them
on something that really weren't getting
what they were going to get or that I
can't tell you how many people have come
to us after spending thousands and
thousands of dollars on a website hmm
only to go I really don't know what I'm
selling it I was like what I don't
really know my market plan for three
years five years out into the market but
how could you proceed how could you take
one step Eve even if it things change
and the markets constantly changing you
still need to step out the door with a
solid plan and yeah it's it's sad how
many people come to us after the fact
and we have to restore their faith in
humanity themselves not just give them a
brand do you so do you do the work as
well or you have you connect with so
it's like she say okay you need a whole
new website your web site now socks it's
not communicating what you want you then
actually make the website yourself or
you have a key column house absolutely
so we for four years even before brand
new we had a full-service advertising
agency marketing design agency where we
would do anything from a logo to TV
shows and virtual Star Trek conventions
for Paramount so we played big and small
and everywhere in between and then about
a 10 years as I said ago and I said you
know what I got
people back in their power let's focus
on entrepreneurs and they were coming to
us for design but they didn't know who
they were and it was like that's a lot
of power you're giving me you need to
know who your business is and then I can
serve you so much more as an advertising
marketing design agency so we created
brand jr. to teach people how to really
know who their business is and then we
did that for about 10 years and we had
programs and intensives and private
coaching and then recently we realized
that we were helping people put them all
in power but then they were then left to
go out and find people to serve them
from their brand and we said let's do it
all let's bring it all in-house so we're
a full-service agency where we combined
we can help you find the brand and we
can help you communicate we can put you
up in full systems to that have learning
management in it ecommerce affiliate
system blogging everything even your
website is is all together and once
you're not needing to piece together all
these different you know AP ice that
often break then so how do you start
that process of trying to figure out who
you are as an entrepreneur well first
you have to decide that it matters you
know you have to say you know what it
really really doesn't matter that I know
exactly what I'm bringing into the
market there's a great book think it was
Jim Collins good to great if you read
that book years ago all right so you
have to make that decision that it's
valuable you're not just going through
the haze I listen to this this wise
woman on a google hangout and she said I
Know Who I am no you need to make the
decision first that it's important that
you want to create a business that
stands for something and is sustainable
read that book good to great and then
you need to start looking at the
products that you buy without thinking
that's where I always get people to
start to realize if the how brands are
affecting you because you can't affect
the market from a brand standpoint if
you're not aware of how they affect you
so you can see so you
you know viscerally the power of a brand
you start looking around to the products
that you buy without thinking and ask
you a question why why am i buying this
is it is it because I've just it's just
been around for a long time well when
you create your brand from a sense of
sustainability you tell the story that
it's been around it's this this recipe
has been passed down from generation you
find the thing that really affects you
or is it something that you go I like
the price a price it's cheap Dollar
Shave Club you know it's Jeep although
people buy Dollar Shave Club not because
it's cheap because they love the
marketing so you find why the things
that you by then we go through a process
of getting into the core of who you
really are what do you stand for what
problem you're really fixing what
separates you from everybody else in the
market even doing the same thing and
then how do we communicate it in a way
that people feel it instantly that's
really our work it's good it's exciting
it's important work it's powerful work
it is really it's really interesting
when I watch somebody come in and they
let's say they've worked on their name
or their their logo or something in
there they're grap they're holding on to
their name like it's it's everything
right and they didn't go to her through
a process to get it they just came up
with an idea they queried their friends
and they go that's a cool clever idea
and they're like holding on to this this
name like it's a safety line and we go
through the process and it's interesting
to see them release the grip and really
get into a place of power of knowing
like wow this is who I really am they
they're a veto and I vetoes my partner
we always we go where's the pop we
always say we do you think the pops
going to be what step is of the pop
meaning there's this this top of
recognition there's this pop that
happens in every on to every single
person that all of a sudden it goes I
Know Who I am and there's this power
that comes over them and it's like from
there now we start and eat there's like
in the brand process there's about I
think there's eight nine steps
and everybody pops at a different place
how longs it take to get the pop it
depends on each person um it depends on
what their how much they've lost faith
in humanity you know how much how much
they've been screwed over by you know
other people promising stuff or their
own disbelief in terms of their support
system growing up and it depends on
depends on them but the process itself
doesn't take long we've got it down
because it's process-based we can
actually work with an individual and get
their brand defined in two days in
person you know like one hundred percent
focus on us we take you through the
process we get name tag line colors
visuals everything done in two days
that's privately um but if somebody's
working with us privately over the phone
it could take three weeks you know with
life right now where are you actually
physically based we're in Los Angeles
okay cool but we work with people all
around / me next time out to LA I'm
gonna lick you up please do what has
coffee uh yeah I'm upward um can you
give an example of a recent client
you've worked with just to kind of bring
it home for the people watching I sure
sure I wasn't even what happened ah
let's see a recent client we've just
recently launched her now this is a full
service client where we helped her
develop the brand and then we also set
her up in on a website systems really
helped her do her first campaigns in
terms of name collection we hooked her
up with video SEO and you know really
getting her known it was a woman who was
a teacher I you're on the East Coast
right yeah she's in New Jersey so she
was in New Jersey or she said it was she
still has in New Jersey and she was a
teacher and she had been struggling and
bouncing around in the information you
know going to tell the seminars people
telling her all these different things
to do to do her business and she just
wasn't getting any anything she really
wasn't getting anything solid done so
she came to us we helped her launch her
brand get clear on what what it is that
she really is doing and who was
her market she came up with a product or
really a company called fortuigence and
it helps she was a teacher and she's
helping homeschooling parents develop
better skills to teach their children oh
it was and we was really working her
through to a point of having a solid
business up until up until she worked
with us it was just an idea and a hope
and a desire and a and a real a real
passion to helping kids learn and then
when we really worked with her and got
her to understand that her market was
really the parents giving them the tools
to teach their kids everything opened up
everything's opened up she and I'm
really proud of her she's now doing her
own campaign she's doing she's offering
I don't know what she's offering free
Kindle reports now and I'm so proud of
her um and she's doing she's really
kicking butt so that's somebody who we
recently worked with we're working with
somebody now which is kind of a funny
project to me it makes me laugh it's
it's it's numerology okay then taking
numerology from a rationalist point of
view and turning it into you know
numbers is just the process right its
technology so she's using technology in
that way to launch a business um and you
describe the the pop moment for either
those two that that you can remember
going through with them uh for the 42
urgence it was the pop moment for her
was when she realized that her market
wasn't kids hmm when she realized that
there's no way in hell that she's going
to reach high schoolers you know hey
learn how to write an essay you know
like they're not going to care about
that but if she reached the the
homeschooling parents who are really
trying to you know and and and here's a
teacher who had been in the education
system so she could talk from the
problems from within the education
system she spoke the homeschooling
language so when she realized that our
market was the parents and that she
wasn't just a teacher and that was
another moment when she realized she
wasn't a teacher any longer
a business owner right okay and that was
a huge huge pot for her cool yeah it's
going so when people hire you is it is
it like intense for a while and then it
phases out or how does the process
usually work yeah that's really
interesting and I was going to say one
other client that I can record we can
talk about I'll talk about this client
after your question what is me I'm now a
client of brand new and I'm like yeah
I'm my own client then um excuse me um
the question was how long how intense
excuse me a moment 10 you can do
coaching sessions with yourself no I
can't no thank goodness there's a veto
because when I think I know because I'm
like working with other people it's so
interesting to take off that at knowing
and be in the same pain and the same
torture that the entrepreneurs are in
themselves not the process but that you
know their own self torture like what am
i creating yeah um it is intense in the
beginning because you're having to peel
away like they said that safety net you
know all these things that you hold onto
because it's it's a lot of work to take
something that you imagine and make it
solid right you're you're grappling with
your own self belief and the you know
the pressures from the outside world
going that's not real you're just a
dreamer whatever it is so we hold on to
things to help make it real so that's
one of the things I think is pretty
intense to let go of that what we
thought we needed to make it real to
really make it real I think the intense
part two is coming up with languaging
because words means so much and there's
so many pressures for people to come up
with the right word you know the right
word combination to come up with the
name of the company got to get the URL
got to get the trademark got to get you
know there's so many pressures and I
think it's pretty intense to come to
peel away all that to get to the right
language
that's just right for the brand or the
product separate from all that and most
of the time when we get to the right
words it's cleared you get the URL you
get that but it but we have to peel away
that need to get to the right language
and its intent that part's intense and
I'd say the biggest intense is of is
somebody really owning owning how big
they could be they have a dream but when
we really get to it can you are they
really believing in it so if I'm if I'm
a new client and we go through our so
I'm not based in la i'm gonna call you
up and say Kim uh-huh want you to help
me then it's about three weeks at the
beginning for that first kind of intense
process is three weeks it could take
faster I mean we worked with somebody
privately over over the phone and in a
week it could take faster it really
depends on the individual and how come
how committed meaning not how much they
believe in themselves but how much time
commitment they can commit to the
process so we walk their specific steps
so we've broken in brand new there's
three stages that we call the from from
idea to market and the we call power
path is stage one where you're coming up
with the concept how do we really put it
into a structure and what's the real
rollout plan what are we really looking
is it just one product are we talking at
the product level or the divisional
level is that the umbrella what are we
really changing how big do we see all
that has to come up first and then we in
that period of time we typically come up
with some product or something so that
you get some generous of money
generating right get something moving
then we move into the brand process
stage to brand power where we that's
where we get into the hard core brand
communication and we decide what and the
cool thing about the process is you can
use it at any level the company umbrella
level you can do it at a divisional or
product all the way down to the product
level so you can use that process again
and again we tell people you could write
a book we've we've taken people through
the brand process to write their book
and you write it fast because you have
the clarity of oh my god this is what
this is about
you don't spend that time kind of
churning until you get something solid
but it depends I mean if you're just the
typical person going through just bring
a stage to brand power over the phone
typically is about a month yeah meaning
they've got life they've got business
they've got all these other things but
it doesn't have to be that long it could
be faster and then stage stage 3 is
market power is where now that you have
the brand how do we really roll it out
into a reliable repeatable sustainable
system basically we call it marketing
prep but it's so much more it's coming
up with all your products coming up with
your marketing funnel you drip your
understanding of how do you take your
brand and make original products born
from the concept of the brand so it's
it's it's really a repeat it's a
repeatable understanding what marketing
really is not running after tactics
right and then ongoing if they have new
products are launching you come back
make sure as kind of thing absolutely
and then and that's really that's the
brand communication side then we also
have the side we call it Enterprise
accelerator where people can come in and
say hey I've got an idea I need your
help to actually do it I need your help
to actually produce it make it do my
reports get develop my website do my
video SEO what what videos do I need for
SEO we do all of it we actually
physically do it it's not just
information we're a full-service agency
right cool now that's why I brand you
client now because it got to a point
where it's like you know what I've been
helping entrepreneurs for all these
years um it's time to really launch my
own brand so what is your new brand what
are you launching um it's interesting
it's in development and it's basically a
wellness it's a lifestyle brand women's
well-being I've launched it through
digital media I have a youtube channel
people can learn learn about me Kim Kim
castle youtube it's called Kim TV at the
moment as I'm really learning what this
brand is allowing it to
for me rather than rather than as a art
director creative director I can come up
with an idea and muscle to it but I
didn't want to do that I wanted this to
be more organic and allow it in this day
and age brands Grover them with an
audience and I really wanted to develop
this with an audience so my focus right
now is really with the audience is
communicating from the audience my
audience is 40 plus women and what's
really fascinating is launching it
through media today people don't realize
the amazing tools that we have to really
reach mass-market appeal if you use them
and I think digital is the biggest way
to go digital video I believe that we've
surpassed the information age it's dead
or on its last breath because it's so
much coming at our head we then we've
been you know intellectualized today
there's only so much our brain can
handle another ten tell us someone our
another webinar no wonder we watch the
Kardashians we need a break you know so
I think I think digital video is the way
we're going to experience everything be
it hobbies be it business expansion viet
relationships be it spirituality and i
think everybody needs to develop their
brand using digital video creating shows
and whether you're the on-camera person
or you're just developing the
information that you have off a for-hire
person and so that's really what i'm
doing um and i'm sharing the entire
journey so as ever the brand you know
educator I have this thing that's called
naked Kim Darroch naked Kim I know brand
where people get to join me behind the
scenes and learn everything that I'm
going through everything that it takes
to launch a brand a mass-market brand
using digital video and beyond no it's
yeah it's
it's basically a reality series without
the shell so that's Kim TV on YouTube
well you can see the public face which
is the final product on YouTube YouTube
Kim castle or you can go to naked Kim
calm and you can see what I'm doing in
terms of so you see the front face with
YouTube what how I'm doing it but then
you don't get to see everything that's
going on behind the scenes in terms of
the strategies that I'm taking you see
the show changing you see you learn
basically the whole world of monetizing
YouTube and if people so people want to
then learn more about brand you is the
best places to go to the range Brandi
that's the letter U com okay perfect can
we're bumping up against a clock it's
been great it's in great to actually you
know talk to you finally and always
different it has been amazing ah a lot
of entrepreneurs definitely don't know
how to mark and bren themselves and
you're providing a great service in the
market so so thank you and thank you for
spending the time today oh my joy I'd
love to give a free gift if somebody
wants so let me reiterate all the
different ways to reach us Brandi calm
there's a free gift there at Brandi calm
called the seven secrets to today's top
earning brands it's free you here I
break down seven seven strategies and I
that big brands are doing so you see
what the big brands are doing and then i
should say are the same seven strategies
that entrepreneurs are doing so you see
it's not just a big brand its
entrepreneurial it's it's you if you're
starting a business and then if you want
to watch how to launch a brand using
digital media and really play it a
bigger bigger level level and watch me
be naked go to naked kim calm and I mean
that literally and figuratively because
I peel it all off and then um yeah if
you want to see what it looks like from
the public face you can go to youtube
very cool thank you so much Kim I'm
gonna check it out myself please do and
it's a joy to finally meet you and
connect and I just I've just watched
what you've done over these years and
it's it's friend it's really been
wonderful to watch you you know own what
you're doing and and you know I could
see your
shifts and changes is you really you
know stepped into the fullest of your
power and it's fun and enjoy to watch
you tell you the truth you know you
don't know who's watching you from you
know you just do what you do and it's
been a joy to watch you grow well this
is gonna go live on i mean it is live on
youtube but it's going to go up and
usually get some questions so bility
washing do you have questions leave it
below and if we have enough maybe we'll
do another session with Kim don't do
wonderful and when you come you're out
to LA give me a call I will thanks Kim
okay bye all right